romain colas est le nouvel homme fort de
l'opti voix après plusieurs semaines de
crise interne et de non gouvernance le
conseil d'administration a élu l'actuel
2e vice-président de l'office lors de la
réunion du 17 décembre à 33 ans romain
colas remplace le président
démissionnaire michel vialay mais le
maire de boussy-saint-antoine la firme
il n'occupait ce poste que pour assurer
une transition et redonner de la
crédibilité à cet office public il
fallait assurer la continuité de l'opi
voix avec notamment le vote du budget
2013 approuvé à l'unanimité ce 17
décembre
cette crise politique n'a pas eu de
répercussion sur les locataires dès les
premiers jours de janvier une nouvelle
réunion est prévue avec les présidents
de conseils généraux le travail
quotidien de l'opi voix n'a pas été
perturbée surtout ces signatures ces
engagements ont pu être honorées mais il
était nécessaire que nous des libériens
hier soir pour assurer cette continuité
et avec une mission claire qui m'a été
assignée par le conseil d'administration
c'est de remettre tout le monde autour
de la table d'appeler les uns et les
autres à la raison pour que nous
puissions trouver les voies et moyens
d'une gouvernement se stable pérenne